you know going back to what you did as a
doctor look
um i don't i don't know if this is for
you like how many total surgeries would
you say you've done
what's the total amount of heart
surgeries you think you've done no well
over ten thousand
well over ten thousand okay i wanna ask
you a question you can totally
decline to answer this one but uh you
know
for for being in the military
the last thing you wanted to do was
deliver any kind of bad news to anyone
and sometimes you have to deliver bad
news to
someone's spouse and hey your husband is
there or your son is there it's a very
painful thing to do
and that job i know a couple of my
friends who had that job
let me tell you when their day was over
with you you did not want to look at
them because they just sometimes it was
not a
easy day for them and that's their job
that's what they're supposed to do some
of them that had been around for a
little long time
still hurt them but they knew was part
of the job have you
ever lost patience and if you did what
was the first someone that happened to
you what was your reaction the first
time it happened to you
well one of the things that you do
have to have in your head
going in is that you
are not going to lose this patient that
there's no way that you would even
go in thinking that you would
and it's it's like um
what terry bradshaw used to say every
pass i
ever threw was for a touchdown
when it left my hand and i think that's
the same sort of attitude you have to
have i
i became famous as a surgeon who would
operate
on people who were inoperable who were
turned down
and so i knew going in that uh
some people were not going to make it
out
and i've had in the years i had people
who
i would have never guessed that they you
know
were not going to make it through the
surgery
and yet looking back the family would go
and say
gosh you know we went back to the house
and
and mom had made casseroles for dad
for two weeks and she left
notes of you know here's where
everything is
you know it's like she knew and you know
i'd go why didn't you tell me
but one of the things uh there's a
famous
saying that that surgeons carry around a
cemetery in their head
and if you're a good surgeon you visit
that
cemetery and you you go to that cemetery
to learn
from the people that didn't come out
alive
and you know what could you have done
differently and i think
i hope that that's what makes a good
surgeon
from a not so good surgeon i i knew a
heart surgeon
that lost patience and that surgeon
would say
uh poor bastard it was just his time
you can't do that you have to you have
to learn
from the people who don't make it and
you know what would i have done
differently um
i'll give you another great example i
was talking about this earlier i
have a patient who's now 15 years from
the time
i was scheduled to take him into the
operating room he had had a massive
heart attack
he had five vessel coronary artery
disease we scheduled him for surgery
we're down going into the operating room
and he looks at me says doc
i'm scared to death he says i don't
think i'm going to make it
and i said well wait a minute yeah good
okay i'm glad you feel this way
because i take this seriously he says
isn't there any other way
and i said well yeah i said look if you
become
my best patient i promise you
you will never be operated on you know
by me or anybody else
i said but you got a promise to be my
best patient he said oh i'll do anything
i'll do anything
we just celebrated his 15th year
from me not operating on him wow
he was a bad diabetic he now passes his
stress
tests we joke about it that's cool
yeah and so it's never too late
which is one of the messages but
yeah you got a yeah you're right uh and
i was a children's heart surgeon too and
there's
you know it's it's one thing to maybe
you know lose somebody who's had a great
life and they're
80 or 85 but it's another thing when
it's a newborn baby
or a two-year-old or a three-year-old
that has their entire hopefully life
ahead of them and they don't
they don't make it now the only reason
we operate on these children is because
they
have no future unless we are able to put
their hearts back together
but still it doesn't make it any easier
to
to live with that um so
you have to you have to have a cemetery
you visit
and luckily i have one um
i was actually visiting that cemetery
this morning
um just to visit it
yeah to me i can only imagine how
emotional it can be you know for
for somebody who does it like the way
you're saying it right now where
you have that relationship to to sit
down with a patient and say if you
listen to me
15 years when my dad had his first heart
attack
94 i can tell you exactly where i was i
came out of high school i was in 10th
grade
i was at the kitchen off of broadway
1323 broadway my friend art was there
with me my mom's cooking something my
sister calls me saying dad had a heart
attack
and i ran to the hospital and saw him
there it was a
interesting moment but my dad listened
to his doctor and the doctor said maybe
you got 10 more years if you make this
that's 94 from a massive heart attack
yet until today
so i salute doctors like yourself out
there what you do is
patriotic we need people like you to do
what you do because without you
there'll be a lot of people out there
that wouldn't have those additional
years with their families so
so salute to folks like you that do what
you do on a daily basis
i appreciate you personally personally
for sharing that
wisdom and perspective with us